ein zehnter planet in unserem
sonnensystem also neben planet 9 noch
ein weiterer möglicher weise können wir
ihm schon ganz bald auf die schliche
kommen ein forschungsteam aus den usa
hat das äußere sonnensystem jenseits der
neptun waren ganz genau ins visier
genommen und vermutet dort noch
mindestens einen weiteren felsplaneten
und schon bald könnte ihn ein neues
teleskop aufspüren klicks um saint lucia
hegels dreimal pro woche spannende
science videos abonniert den kanal und
aktiviert die glocke nur so verpasst ihr
nichts los geht's
herzlich willkommen zwergplaneten pluto
siedler und ehre sie alle sind im
äußeren sonnensystem jenseits der neptun
bahn unterwegs genauso wie wohl viele
kleinere objekte und kometen doch hier
muss etwas fehlen davon sind manche
astronomen und astronomen überzeugt so
zum beispiel die beiden us fachleute
kätzchen volk und brad man in einer
aktuellen studie schreiben sie es
scheint unwahrscheinlich dass die natur
vier kerne große gasplaneten entstehen
ließ aber im äußeren sonnensystem nichts
das größer ist als die bekannten
zwergplaneten wenn man sich die planeten
in unserem sonnensystem genauer ansieht
sind diese eigentlich recht ordentlich
nach größe und zusammensetzung
sortiert doch laut volk und batman
scheint es so als würde etwas fehlen der
hypothetische planet 10 und bereits in
früheren studien hatten
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
bereits hinweise darauf gefunden dass es
dort im weit entfernten äußeren
sonnensystem noch mindestens einen
weiteren felsplaneten geben könnte die
heutige konstellation der planeten sowie
modellierung der entstehung und
entwicklung des sonnensystems legten
genau dass nach dieser mysteriöse
zehnter planet im äußeren sonnensystem
müsste eine größe haben zwischen der vom
mars und erde wie können wir uns diesen
zehnten planeten vorstellen und wo genau
steckt er wurde er womöglich bereits vor
langer zeit aus dem sonnensystem
herausgeschleudert das us forschungsteam
hat jetzt eine neue studie zu diesem
super spannenden thema veröffentlicht
alle infos dazu gibt es jetzt hier bei
pixum future gleich zwei planeten sind
es die sich möglicherweise sogar
heutzutage noch in unserem sonnensystem
bewegen ohne dass wir sie bislang auf
spur zum einen der mysteriöse planet 9
und zum anderen noch ein weiterer planet
planet 10 über planet 9 oder nein haben
wir hier bei klicks ums ganze ja bereits
öfter berichtet es handelt sich wohl um
einen etwa neptun großen planeten über
dessen existenz fachleute weltweit
bereits seit vielen jahren spekulieren
dazu schreibt einer der beiden entdecker
von plänen der us astronom michael braun
vor einigen monaten in seinem blog vor
fünf jahren haben wir erstmals die
existenz von planeten ein vorgeschlagen
jetzt haben wir die vielleicht
wichtigste etappe bei der konkreten
suche danach geschafft wir wissen jetzt
wo wir suchen müssen fachleute weltweit
gehen davon aus dass es sich um einen
gesteinsplaneten mit dem vierfachen er
durchmesser handeln könnte dass es ihn
geben muss das legen viele verschiedene
modelle und simulationen denn seine
existenz könnte sehr auffällige bahn
abweichungen mehrerer großer objekte im
kuipergürtel erklären genau dort könnte
er sich auch versteckt halten im
sogenannten körper göttl diesen kann man
sich wie eine ringförmige zunahme aus
dem rand unseres sonnensystems
vorstellen eine flache region die sich
außerhalb der bahn des äußersten
planeten neptun einige hundert
astronomische einheiten weit ins all
erstreckt kurze erklärung eine
astronomische einheiten entspricht dem
abstand erde-sonne also knapp 150
millionen kilometer ihr könnt
möglicherweise mehr als 70.000 als
körper mit mehr als 100 kilometern
durchmesser kreisen zu dem auch viele
kleinere objekte wie kometen auch der
zwergplanet pluto zählt zu den so
genannten kuipergürtel objekten seitdem
der planeten status aberkannt wurde doch
klar ist schon lange die entdeckung
eines neuen planeten ist alles andere
als ein kinderspiel die sogenannten
transnet mission objekte sind wirklich
extrem super spricht auch zu spüren denn
sie befinden sich jenseits von neptun
und sind von der erde aus gesehen extrem
nicht schwach der außenbereich des
sonnensystems wurde bis heute nicht
vollständig abgesucht trotz intensiver
forschung konnte der planet nein also
nicht aufgespürt werden ähnlich geht es
astronomie teams weltweit mit planet 10
dieser könnte kleiner sein als der
hypothetische planet nein und sich vor
allem nicht ganz so weit draußen im
transnet technischen bereich aufhalten
bereits vor vier jahren hatte das us
team um die astronomen kerzen folk erste
hinweise auf einen möglichen zehnten
planeten gefunden damals hatten die
fachleute die körper gürtel objekte
cadiot genauer ins visier genommen die
eigentlich in der gleichen ebene wie die
großen planeten um die sonne kreisen
sollten doch schon damals fanden die
forscher heraus dass sich einige der
objekte nicht in dieser sogenannten
ebene der ekliptik bewegen ihr orbit ist
tatsächlich und bis zu 8 grad gegenüber
dieser ebene gekippt dazu die astronomen
kevin faulk die wahrscheinlichste
erklärung unserer messergebnisse ist
dass es dort draußen eine bislang
unentdeckte masse gibt dieser mögliche
zehnter planet könnte also eine
erklärung dafür sein dass es mit seiner
schwerkraft die käufer gürtel objekte
auf eine schiefe bahn lenkt damals
hatten die astronomen unter astronomen
berechnet dass der unbekannte trabant
die sonnen abstand von 60 astronomische
einheiten umkreisen müsste seine
schwerkraft hat demnach möglicherweise
einen einfluss auf bahnen von
himmelskörpern in entfernung von bis zu
10 astronomischen einheiten zu jeder
seite zudem konnte in der damaligen
studie aufgrund der errechneten masse
ausgeschlossen werden dass es sich
hierbei um den mysteriösen planet nein
handelt um zu verstehen wie sich das
sonnensystem gebildet und entwickelt hat
hat das forschungsteam nun in
computersimulationen verschiedene
szenarien getestet auch diesen
berechnungen zufolge könnte es einen
weiteren gesteinsplaneten geben oder
gegeben haben heißt es in der aktuellen
studie denn klar ist die acht planeten
die noch heute in unserem sonnensystem
unterwegs sind sind quasi die letzten
überlebenden denn das planetensystem um
unsere sonne herum ist nicht nur auf
chaotische art und weise entstanden
sondern hat sich zudem seit dem auch
chaotisch entwickelt immer noch sehr
jungen planetensystemen gab es
höchstwahrscheinlich zahlreiche objekte
kleine größere und außerdem auch objekte
die noch an material aus der umgebung
hinzugewonnen haben die sonne sorgte
dafür dass die kleineren objekte nicht
mehr in der lage waren gas festzuhalten
und somit also ohne atmosphäre
existieren anders dagegen in den
regionen die weiter von der sonne
entfernt waren diese objekte namen
weiter an festen material und gas auf
und wuchsen somit zu solch beachtlichen
größe wie der jupiter weil so zahlreiche
objekte existierten kam es zu
gravitative wechselwirkung so dass sich
die bahnen der planeten dadurch zum teil
veränderten wenn auch nur minimal doch
höchstwahrscheinlich gab es auch
wechselwirkungen die zu weitreichenden
konsequenzen für die astronomie teams
gehen davon aus dass durch solche
gravitative wechselwirkung in der
frühphase der entwicklung des
planetensystems manche objekte sogar aus
dem planetensystem herausgeschleudert
worden sein könnten doch die aktuelle
studie offenbart erneut dass die
existenz eines etwa maß großen
felsplaneten im äußeren sonnensystem
eine gute erklärung für die heutige
planeten konstellation wäre doch nicht
auszuschließen ist dass dieser bereits
vor längerer zeit aus unserem
sonnensystem geflogen ist bedingt durch
die schwerkraft wechselwirkung mit
anderen planet möglicherweise ist der
heutzutage als einzelgänger im
interstellaren raum unterwegs demnach
könnte die erde also irgendwo im
interstellaren raum eine verschollene
schwester haben die große frage ist also
ob solch ein fels planet sich immer noch
in unserem sonnensystem befindet oder
eben nicht dazu sagte us astronomen
david nash vorne der nicht an der
aktuellen studie beteiligt war es stimmt
es ist schon wahrscheinlich dass
ursprünglich mal einen planeten mars
größe dort war aber die frage ist ob er
überlebt hat und ob wir beweise dafür
haben auch der us-physiker scott to
maine hat dazu geforscht er sagt in
einem interview mit im worst dot com
unsere simulationen ergaben dass in etwa
der hälfte der fälle maß große planeten
des äußeren sonnensystems in den
interstellaren raum geschleudert wurden
wenn dieser denn tatsächlich noch
innerhalb unseres sonnensystems
existiert könnte planet 10 allerdings
schon bald aufgespürt werden so die
hoffnung einiger astronomen astronom das
wäre ein observatorium soll bereits bald
in zwei jahren 2023 in betrieb gehen es
handelt sich um ein spiegelteleskop das
den zugänglichen himmel in drei nächten
komplett fotografieren kann und auch das
europäische weltraumteleskop kaya ist
möglicherweise in der lage die beiden
bislang unentdeckten planeten
aufzuspüren manno ein von beiden werden
wir hoffentlich bald entdecken ich bin
jedenfalls ziemlich gespannt was da noch
kommt planet neuen großer teil der suche
ist abgeschlossen also ihr könnt schon
bald so weit sein anklicken anschauen
und abonnieren wisst ihr wie es geht ist
kostenlos und macht schlau bis dann
bleibt dran